hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the extra con
open 2019 now I know you're probably
thinking I'm showing this game because
we've already seen a game by by
Charlotte pregnant and the sister but
that is not the case there is a very
good well a better reason I'm showing
this game and I could have shown a
different one for example I could have
shown you pregnant us game against
Antone Corbeau who is well he's not the
top seed but he's the second seed if
that's that's how you say it in the
tournament only by difference by 400
rating points but I decided to show this
one as it's well much more exciting and
the opening choice is well much nicer so
to say so without further ado let's
check it out
pregnant with the white pieces faces
daniel booko Toro the highest rated
Italian Grandmaster eyes of 2017 since
Fabiano Khurana now plays for the United
States and well they're definitely a
tough matchup for for pregnant Landis so
let's see what happens with e4 c5 Knight
to f3 and the Sicilian game is on the
board and now g6 pocket or goes for the
hyperaccelerated dragon which is a very
exciting opening and a favorite amongst
those who are just starting to learn
opening theory as there is much less to
learn than if you try the knight or for
or well I would do normal dragon or the
the delasco variation or something like
that
a bouquet will be 4c captures and
Mountain Knight captures on b4 Queen
captures is also a very nice idea as it
threatens the rook but it's a very nice
line where black will get a lot of
counter play for example Knight f6 z v
non knight c6 attacking both the pawn
and the queen and atropine a4 you move
the knight and then you bring the Queen
back Knight b6 and then it's a nice game
where black and even for example after
Knight c3 sacrifice a pawn to get some
nice you know a nice chances here which
is all very analyzed and of course you
know if it was better for white people
with play it so tonight after Sun before
we have Knight to c6 and now c4 we have
a nice emerald sea bind set up by
pregnant under he wants to play b3 at
some point and f3 and then just enjoy a
superior position we have Knight to f6
attacking the pawn here Knights the c3
and now d6 and the Bishop to e2 with
nightcap recently for Queen captures and
Queen to g7 there is no pressure here as
there are no good discoveries here to be
made by the Knights of white simply
develops with Bishop to e3 baka to rock
castles and Queen to d2 by pregnant
lambda this is the main line that is
being played there are over 1600 games
with this exact same line now white can
castle King side Queen side you can a
place for some Bishop h6 just a get rid
of blacks dragon but black goes a 5
which is the standard setup white will
at some point play b3 so you might be
able to challenge challenges set up by
playing a for b3 at the moment is not
possible since you would wonder the rook
that your rooks are not connected Knight
captures on e4 would be simply too much
to deal with if you if you play b3 for
example so f3 and now a for not allowing
b3 in the future we have King to have 2
castling also possible pregnant on the
prefers king to f2 and now Queen to a5
and now that I know what you're thinking
probably Knight to d5 is a nice trick
you know he captures your queen and then
you snatch a pawn with check and then
only recapture a queen but it doesn't
work because black will just capture
your knight the Queen is protected so
it's not one of those well cheap tricks
so rook 8 2 c1 bye partner Amanda and
now Bishop to e6 and interestingly this
has all been played before and only now
nice to d5 here white uses this well a
nifty little trick to improve his pawn
structure in the center and also to grab
hold of the open C file so here if you
just move back let's say Queen d8 to
defend your East 7 pawn just over the
Queen trade Knight b6 is super strong
the bishop pair is slicing all the way
here and well you don't really have a
good Square for the rook you'd have to
move it and then you lose the a4 pawn
another thing is if you capture with the
night it's not really a good option for
you because after the exchange of Queens
and C captures here you don't really
have a good Square for the bishop your
Bishop is a terrible piece now you can
go here because of rook to c7 and even
after some
little tea here you're also getting rook
to c7 and it's just a terrible
LightSquared bishop so Bishop captures
on d5 it's one of those well positions
where it's just better to give up the
bishop to pair right rather than to have
your bishop useless in hopes of maybe
reactivating it somewhere in the in the
deep end game Queen captures on a5 now
rook captures and pawn captures here and
now pregnant andhe improved his pawn
structure and he's preparing roof to c7
there's nothing black can really do
about it
so Knight to d7 we've roped the c7 and
now Knight to c5 and here white is not
in a rush to either capture here and
then and get rid of the b7 point or to
immediately get rid over the e7 pawn but
first rook the b1 just guarding that B
to pawn so the bishop doesn't take it
away and now Bishop to f6 and there is
only one game that has reached this
position and it's a game between Fabiano
Caruana and Mihail antipov in the zero
star masters 2017 where Fabiano
continued with g4 and he won a very nice
game but it took him what a lot of moves
you know it was a really intense game
but here pregnant nanda improves on
Coronas move he actually plays the
strongest move recommended by the engine
and it is before so it's hard to say if
well it's maybe an even stronger engine
will play a kuranes move I don't know
but you know I don't know if he knows
about the game Caruana versus antipov
but he and I haven't seen if there are
any interviews after the extra crown
games but you know it wouldn't be very
interesting to know if he actually knew
or or if we may be found before over the
board now of course the threat is just
to capture anything here so you have to
capture a captures on b3 i'm poisson we
have a capture some b3 pawn captures
again threatening before and now rook to
a2 with B for attacking the knight
Knight to a4 and now rook beat the c1
not allowing Knight to c3 so you take
away that from the night and now look
the B - so what's pregnant on this point
here why why was before better than g4
and why did he lie would not be under
attack how do you defend it is there a
way to
actually defended well you could capture
on b7 but Brogdon on des has an even
better idea Bishop to h6 where he now
forces in the exchange of dark square
bishop sand this dark square Bishop is
blacks most useful piece so to say the
night here not really doing all that
much and you can't avoid this if you
just move the rook rook c8 leads the
checkmate
there's no way to defend either you move
the bishop and then rook captures or you
capture the other of recaptures and well
for example it will be a very quick mate
so Bishop to g7 now removing the
defender of the e7 pawn bishop capture
screen captures and now rook captures on
e7 so prague none on this idea is just
give up this flank beep-beep on for the
nice central pawn and the end result is
after rook captures on b4 now you can
see that Baca Toro has three porn
islands whereas pregnant Landa has only
one point island again the elusive green
square appears I decided to use it as
it's you know nice way of showing you
that there is only one point chain and
rook see the c7 and already this looks
very ugly two rooks on the seventh rank
it's you know not something you wanna
face in an endgame and g5 by black not
allowing white f4 or h4 but pregnant
andhe uses this to his advantage here he
could go rogue capture some b7 sure it's
it's a move but pregnant on the place in
you know in a great style he plays he
five what is e five doing well he's
threatening just to capture a nice pawn
here so D captures on e5 and now not
recapturing and going for g5 but rare d6
here probably angle starts pushing his
passport d7 and d8 well d7 and obviously
rook rook to e8 is a threat but you
don't want to allow this so rook the d4
putting a room behind a passed pawn
where it's your own phone or your
opponent's pawn and now what's the idea
here Bishop to c4 just a piling up on
the f7 pawn we have rook after sandy six
and now Bishop captures and B on f7
threatening Bushra back to b3 with a
discovered check to become the night
here so King to
it's not allowing any discovered checks
and now official to age five and our
pregnant and is ready to gobble up all
of the pawns we have looked the c6
offering a trade but now rook captures
on b7 Knights the c5 attacking the rook
and now rook to f7 check rook captures
rook captures with check King g6 only
move and now rook captures on h7 so here
again it's three points to two but again
pregnant on the one point island of akka
to row to point Islands and it's a
bishop against tonight
Knight DS a recheck with King to e3 and
now rook the c3 threatening some
discoveries but partner honda says not a
problem
rook h6 check King e7 and now bringing
the King deeper into the position King
before hoping to get King a5 in and get
rid of well the remaining points with
Knight to f4 and now the G to pawn is
under attack
so here almost set Capablanca pregnant
on the plays g3 first I'm just getting
rid of the knight with Knight captures
rook captures and now King to f6
preventing the White King from advancing
but now rook to h6 check came to f7 and
now rook to d6 just giving black a move
so what do you play here Baca to row
went for the h2 pawn and only now that's
pregnant on the capture with King
captures on e5 rook captures on h2 and
now King to f5 so going after the the
last black pawn rook to h3 and now of
course before capturing just in before
for the rook away from her g3 pawn
then you're gonna recapture and then
after rook - well it was in this game
that Daniel vaca - resigned the game but
after you move the rook for example H 1
or H a doesn't matter you're gonna
capture here check me picking a 4 and
you have two points to connect the past
points whereas your opponent has none
it's a completely winning endgame so of
course about Couture knows this and
after king g4 he resigns the game and
well I just thought that you would enjoy
this game very much since it was a
hyperaccelerated dragon a nice use of
the Marazzi bind really just a nice way
of out playing the number one
Grandmaster and also I mentioned that
there is a reason why I showed this game
I mean I chose this game because this is
a game from round seven and after round
7 pregnant Linda is the sole leader of
the extra con open here are his
opponents so we can just enjoy that for
a second so as you can see after four
clean victories he faces pregnant on the
faced re ontari Norwegian Norwegian
Grandmaster he drew that game and then
he defeated Anton horrible the game I
thought about showing the second seed of
the tournament 2687 is his rating so
really just an insane victory but it was
a really a tug of war game where a
horrible blundered severely in the end
game and in program and was able to
capitalize on that and then another nice
victory a very clean one as you've just
seen against Daniel vaca thorough number
one rated Italian grandmasters so really
just exciting program under now on six
and a half out of seven so leader all
the other players sharing second place
with six out of seven so really insane
stuff by young prog really hoping to see
if he can take this you know to the end
when when the extra can open which is
really just a very strong open
tournament would do a lot you know for a
young Prague and for his rating he's
been trying to at the breach 2600 for
quite some time now and it seems that he
was you know a secretly training to
achieve this super form but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Blake redden for a
conversion to my channel thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos so your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with more interesting
content may be checking up what's you
know how probably will do continue in
the Capablanca saga and of course
checking up on your suggestions thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day